des porte-parole de 200 organisations
réunies afin de trouver de nouvelles
pratiques d'affaires à impact social et
environnemental plus positifs en un jour
le défi était de taille et le thème
choisi ne facilitait pas la tâche
la choisissent cet élément sur la
thématique du plastique en est pris avec
cette matière là tous les jours on en
consomme on en utilise les grandes
entreprises telles que thé c est que rig
les pme et les ong devaient répondre à
une question c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait
cette matière commandes
on peut l'utiliser différemment mayer
d'affi sait quoi faire du plastique ça
c'est un de nos meilleurs vendeurs ce
manteau un an nous avons consommé 99
bouteille pour créer ce manteau nous
sommes chez norden une petite entreprise
de quatre employés fruit de l'obsession
de maeyer vaffi trouver une façon de
transformer le plastique
il est stérilisé il y des jt et puis là
l'extraction du pétrole se fait qui est
solidifié en b i avec cb ont créé le
polyester recyclé qui est le fibre donc
nous on utilise ce fibre pour créer
l'isolant la coke et hélas doubleur de
toutes les manteaux nordine qui fait
partie d'une collection c'est
confortable faut essayer les prix 485
détails pour confectionner des manteaux
en quantité industrielle et à prix
abordable
la société fait affaire avec un
partenaire chinois certifiés dans la
poche de chaque moto se trouve une
bouteille en silicone sur laquelle
figure un message de sensibilisation une
bouteille dure quatre cent cinquante ans
présentement on consomme 1 millions de
bouteilles par minute
c'est quand même énorme seulement 7% des
bouteilles produits sont réclamés pour
leur recyclage
fidèle à sa philosophie norden offre
programme de fin de vie la pme demande à
ses clients de garder leurs manteaux au
moins deux ans elle les rachète par la
suite les réparer les revend si possible
ou les faire recycler s'ils sont trop
endommagés
ici maxime bertrand radio canada
montréal